bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag en
2017 saint-quentin-en-yvelines retrousse
ses manches de grands travaux ont d'ores
et déjà commencé à maurepas ya la
verrière qui ajoute le doublement du
coût du swing heures et l'aménagement
des accès à la gare mais aussi attrapé
avec une nouvelle phase de construction
de la zac de l'aérostat prévue pour mars
où nous explique tous et partout
[Musique]
et
t
le pont guy schuller une artère qui fait
la jonction entre les villes de maurepas
et la verrière passage obligé de bon
nombre d'automobilistes
il est saturé aux heures de pointe au
quotidien dix huit mille véhicules et
5000 piétons empruntent le pont et les
transports ces jours ci commence de
grands travaux l'objectif mais
doublement dit tout alors le pot
schuller c'est un point noir important a
pour tous les gens qui vont sur la gare
de la verrière et il était plus que thor
et de le faire de le doubler pour éviter
les supprimer ce point noir ces bouchons
du matin
il faut savoir que tous les matins à
maurepas et aussi tous les soirs nous
avons des bouchons en entrée de ville du
fait que nous avons un passage piéton
qui situé sur la ville de la verrière
juste avant la gare d'ailleurs de
l'accès à la gare et il est prévu dans
le doublement de ce pont un excès
en amont de ce passage piétons vers la
nationale 10 la verrière et le terminus
ou ou la première garde suivante comment
on s'y prend pour aller sur la défense
montparnasse extra donc beaucoup
d'habitants des villes environnantes
viennent prendre le train à la verrière
il y avait nécessité quand même à la
fois 2-2
sécuriser un peu tout ça de fluidifier
le trafic
il ya des moments où c'est vraiment très
très compliqué à la fois compliqué pour
la circulation à la fois un peu
dangereux quand même pour la circulation
des piétons ou les vélos même si un vélo
se risque à passer par là après enquête
publique et dix ans de concertation
entre l'agglomération les différentes
villes partenaires du projet une
première phase vient d'être réalisée
avec le dévoiement des réseaux d'eau de
gaz et d'assainissement
mais le gros des travaux c'est
maintenant et c'est parti pour 24 mois
fluidifier le trafic améliorer
l'efficacité des bus renforcer
l'intermodalité tout en sécurisant les
parcours et le franchissement de la rn10
et faciliter ainsi l'accès à la gare de
la verrière
les objectifs de ces travaux sont
multiples et tout d'abord le doublement
du pont dit chaleur la nouvelle voie à
double sens sera réservée à l'aline tcsp
et aux bus avec entre le pot et le
rond-point des cités a mis la création
d'un carrefour à feux avec une priorité
donnée aux bus
la ligne de tcsp reliera à terme la gare
de la verrière à celle de trappes
on espère quand même jusque les les gens
qui prennent leur voiture aujourd'hui et
plus d'intérêt à prendre des bus qui
vont font enfin rouler mieux est donc
arrivé à l'heure normalement donc on
espère que ça incitera un certain nombre
de personnes à prendre le bus
les circulations douces ne sont pas
oubliés une piste cyclable
bidirectionnelle continue et sécurisé
sera créée depuis maurepas jusqu'à la
gare de la verrière un trottoir sera
réservée aux piétons une nouvelle voie
sera aussi créée entre le boulevard guy
schuller et la rue louis normand celle
ci sera réservé à tous les véhicules
la traversée piétonne entre la
passerelle et la gare sera davantage
sécurisée puisque la voix franchi sera
dorénavant réservé aux bus la gare
routière l'axé parking la station de
taxis et les dépose minute
brest et sa lance les grands chantiers
d'avenir qui sont que sont donc la
rénovation de la gare de la verrière le
carrefour de la même donne qui va
désengorger vraiment à terme l'ensemble
de ce secteur
en effet le giratoire de la malle me
donne sera lui entièrement réaménagé
l'insertion des automobilistes sur la
rn10 devrait au final être simplifiée et
plus rapides et deux ans a surmonté
couler mais le prochain semestre verra
l'installation de ce nouveau tronçon du
pouls à pont métallique installée lors
d'une opération nocturne afin
d'occasionner le moins de gêne possible
j'invite les gens à venir à pied bien
évidemment pour assister à cette
opération parce que la mise en place
d'un pont c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et
de relier deux parties de
l'agglomération je dirais pas séparés
mais difficile d'accès je partais l'eau
les premiers bus eux pourront rouler sur
le nouveau tronçon dès septembre
prochain
et adieu les bouchons oui enfin pas tout
de suite parce qu'on attend dans le
trafic va forcément être perturbée et la
circulation se fera pendant une période
en circulation alternée
donc ça va très certainement râler il
faudra que les automobilistes essaye de
trouver des itinéraires de contournement
ça génère quelques difficultés mais
voilà pas moyen de faire autrement on va
falloir prendre son mal en patience
c'est sûr mais c'est un mal pour un bien
le coût de la première séquence du tcsp
ce qui est estimé à 8,76 millions
d'euros dont 66 % sont prises en charge
par le département des yvelines
la région ile de france et l'état les
travaux à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est aussi l'habitat avec la zac de
l'aérostat attrape c'est un projet de
850 logements qui à terme sortira de ted
petit viser une urbanisation diversifiée
et de qualité
tel est le projet de ce nouveau quartier
trappistes entre centres villes et
quartiers des merisiers commencé en 2009
l'opération immobilière se déroule en
trois phases
3 124 logements appartements et maisons
de villes ont déjà été réalisées dont
une majorité en accession à la propriété
sont déjà occupés labellisé haute
qualité environnementale et très haute
performance énergétique
ces logements sont réalisés par divers
promoteurs la deuxième tranche est
toujours en exécution avec à terme 350
logements
la dernière partie devrait aboutir en
les données c'est 40 % d'habitants de
trappes qui ont acheté que des ménages
ou ou kid et cohabitent à peu près 40%
qui sont de la région
et puis 20% de personnes qui veut dire
qu'ils viennent d'ailleurs eux qui
viennent
or hors agglomération dès le début du
mois de mars
il luttera la dernière phase de
l'opération un appel à projets sera
alors lancé les travaux se dérouleront
jusqu'en 2019 trappe accueillera alors à
nouveau quartier de nouvelles rues pour
un nouveau visage de la ville sur la rue
maryse bastié on a voulu que le tout le
rez de chaussée autour de la place au
bal etc ça que tous les rez-de-chaussée
soit noblesse par des commerces avec
quelques quelques activités économiques
une auto école par exemple des commerces
avec au-dessus différents types
d'habitat du studio au 5 pièces pour 70%
d'entre eux 30% de logements
intermédiaires 50% en accès libre 20% de
locatif social et 15 % en accession
aidée coût global de l'opération 7
millions trois cent vingt mille euros
l'aménagement et en particulier des
actes font partie la compétence de
l'agglomération donc l'agglomération
elle a eu à faire toutes les études
urbaines justement aussi toutes les
études qui ont trait aux réseaux voirie
dans le projet mais tout ça se fait
toujours en concertation avec la commune
c'est un très très gros travail de
partenariat d'allers retours mais la
commune bien sûr a le dernier mot parce
que c'est important que le maire puisse
donner le visage qu'il veut au quartier
qui est en train de se construire
c'est ainsi que l'avenue salvador
allende va faire l'objet d'importants
travaux de dévoiement et de création de
réseaux mais sans pour autant encombrer
les accès des résidences sand pergaud et
verlaine
parallèlement une voie provisoire sera
mise en place entre le carrefour de la
croix thorez delago et la place ovale
avant l'instauration du tcsp qui reliera
la gare de trappes à la gare de la
verrière
le my de l'aqueduc conservera son aspect
paysager pour offrir un lieu de
promenade et de détente privilégié aux
habitants jusqu'à l'île de loisirs
urbanis et cadre de vie était si on vit
dans un endroit de de qualité agréable
on a des relations et une vingt quand
mon meilleur que si on vit dans des
endroits et qu'ils sont moches pas
prendre du poids gérer chaque architecte
à importer son talent le fleurissement
le paysagement l'organisation des
matériaux tout ça ça donne de la qualité
de vie ça donne des rues des russes
enfin quoi les personnes qui habitent au
delà des détails a toujours des détails
dans l'avenir mais aux dix ans on est au
d content d'être venu là mais au fait
qu'est-ce qu'une zac une ville
d'activités commerciales pas vraiment
non
voyons plutôt créé par la loi
d'orientation foncière de 1967
une zac zone d'aménagement concerté
permet à une collectivité publique
d'engager une opération d'envergure pour
un aménagement cohérent de l'espace
urbain
la réalisation d'un projet est alors
précédé d'une étude de faisabilité et
d'une concertation
ce n'est en fait qu'un outil
d'aménagement par d'autres
mais l'intérêt d'une zac quand on a
beaucoup de logements à construire c'est
que ça permet de prévoir les équipements
publics qui vont répondre aux besoins
des futurs habitants les équipements
publics sont les écoles gymnases réseaux
voirie et espaces verts
la vente des terrains permet de
subventionner l'opération la zac permet
donc de se projeter dans l'avenir
une zac qui peut durer des années le
temps pour le projet d'être construit
dans sa globalité comme la construction
de la zac de l'aérostat alors c'est un
projet ambitieux puisque ses 850
logements
donc c'est un projet sur une zone qui
était en friche pendant très très
longtemps qu'ils n'avaient pas été
aménagé par la ville nouvelle et donc
qui permet à la ville de trappes de
poursuivre ou terminer son développement
et surtout de mieux relier les quartiers
entre
sur le territoire de saint quentin il ya
encore beaucoup de besoins de logements
est essentiellement aussi pour nos
salariés
donc c'est important de pouvoir y
répondre d'autres travaux vont également
se dérouler dans l'agglomération comme
ici à guyancourt où à voisins le
bretonneux
on jette un coup d'oeil à guillon coup
le réaménagement de l'ancien groupe
scolaire lurçat a débuté fin janvier à
terme 147 logements et quatre maisons
individuelles devraient voir le jour
l'agglomération réaménage l'ancien
parvis dans le cadre de l'accompagnement
intercommunale il s'agit de créer un
espace ouvert entre ville et forêts et
d'en simplifier les accès les abords
pour les piétons seront sécurisés des
pistes de circulations douces seront
créés le nombre de places de parking
sera maintenu enfin le réseau et le
mobilier d'éclairage seront modernisés
priorité aux led pour plus d'économies
les travaux d'un montant de 725 1000
euros devrait s'achever en juin 2010 est
à voisins le bretonneux le département
expérimente depuis janvier et pour six
mois
le réaménagement du carrefour à l'angle
de l'avenue de la pyramide et de la rd36
une opération en prévision du futur
développement de la zone d'aménagement
concerté de la remise
le but de ce test est de sécuriser les
divers usages et d'améliorer la
lisibilité du carrefour et de prévenir
les accidents et de renforcer les
déplacements interquartiers nous en
savons un peu plus sur les travaux qui
se déroulent actuellement sur
l'agglomération
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]
oui